hi everybody we're going to start a
minute early here just to make sure that
everything looks okay and clear
hi everybody thanks so much for joining
we're just gonna give a minute here to
make sure everything looks clear and
ready to go
awesome well I just got the okay from
the team so hi everybody Welcome again
so nice to see you all here today so in
the data science Hangouts and meetups we
repeatedly hear about the importance of
showcasing your work from data science
leaders across every industry
so whether you're thinking about
building your personal brand to break
into data science transition to a new
role
or maximize the impact of the work
within your current position
you need to make it easy for others to
explore your data projects however
putting projects together in a clean
format and maintaining them can be
difficult
so this is something I'm really excited
to explore quarto for
in our fourth quarto Meetup of the
series
you can view the recordings of past
sessions at the link which I'll share in
the chat in just a minute here
um but those other quarto meetups are
welcome to quarto Workshop building a
Blog with Cordo and building reports and
presentations
today you'll learn how to create a data
science portfolio website and instantly
deploy it using Cordo
you'll also learn how to easily maintain
and update this portfolio whenever you
need to Showcase new projects
uh as always with meetups there will be
a few ways to ask questions today you
can ask right from the YouTube chat or
you can use the slido link which I will
pull up on the screen here and I'll put
it into the chat so you can copy and
paste it but you're able to ask
questions anonymously there as well
I am very grateful and excited to have
deepsham mangani joining us for today's
event
is a senior data scientist at Microsoft
focusing on investment impact analysis
and propensity modeling
when she is not geeking out over data
she is knitting or collecting yarn so I
love to pull you up on stage with me
here deepsha and turn it over to you
thank you so much
awesome thanks Rachel
um hi everyone my name is deepsha and
today I'm very excited to talk about how
to create your data science portfolio
with cuarto which is something that I
have done myself so I will hope it's a
hopeful session for everybody but before
we talk about jump into the quarto
portion of it let's give a brief minute
to what is a data science portfolio to
ground everybody so usually we use the
data science portfolio to Showcase some
of our best works and showcase our
skills as a data scientist the
components of a data science portfolio
are usually a brief About Me section
some of your favorite projects your
resume and ways to connect with you in
case somebody looks at your website and
likes what they say a good portfolio
website usually is catchy so what people
are reading they want to continue
reading more about it it should be
simple and concise and easy to navigate
people visiting your data science
portfolio website should be able to find
what they're looking for and the last
thing it should be up to date so which
means that if let's say you did a brand
new project or change your employment
had something anything change you should
easily be able to update it and have the
most latest information on your website
awesome having said that we all know
what a data science portfolio is how
important it is but just at the thought
of creating one it can be a little bit
intimidating and daunting and that's
what my initial thought was until I saw
cuarto and how easy it made it look just
creating your website and so before we
go into that I just want to showcase a
example portfolio website that I created
just so everybody again grounds as to
what it looks like so this is my website
with uh on the front page there is my
photo my a brief description about
myself all the ways to connect with me
and if you click the links you'll find
my projects uh note that these are all
external projects so somebody clicks on
this these are projects that I already
had before I sat down to create my
website so this is a medium blog that I
had written on data science stakeholders
then I also have a blogs that are within
my website so this is a tidy Tuesday is
a weekly data
visualization even that's run by the
posit community so this is my
submissions for that so if you click on
this you see that the code is all within
the website and anybody who wants to
draw that plot is able to see the code
and do that then I have two types I have
uploaded a resume one is uploading an
existing PDF resume in as part of your
website which almost all of us have and
then just to show an example that you
can also create your resume within the
cuarto website I created a
resume for Wednesday Adams because she's
my absolute favorite character
um and gave talked about her AI
experience which I think she's
absolutely amazing at uh the advantage
of doing that is that you can also add
Charts made with this is made with Gigi
plot and GG trans uh as a part of your
resume so you can be creative about that
so now that we have an example of a
portfolio website let me jump back into
why I chose cuarto to build this so
first of all cuarto is an open source
scientific and Technical publishing
system uh built on Pandora so we will
see how it is used to publish anything
but the advantage of using it is you can
be tool and language agnostic because
cuarto supports multiple languages and
tools or IDs that you are familiar with
the base blog website skeleton that
cuarto provides when you try to create
that project is just by default so clean
uh looking that I had to do very little
work to make my website look the way I
wanted to wanted it to look and it was
very quick and easy to update now even
if you have a very basic understanding
going into this of any of your quarto
supported languages and IDE you should
be able to build it I'm going to be
using rstudio and R today but you can
use other IDs and languages that you are
comfortable with so cuarto comes
installed with our studio but for other
platforms you can install it very easy
if you want to learn how to do that I've
Linked In the footnote here you can go
to this site and check out those options
perfect so what we will cover today is
configuring your website so you saw the
tabs that I had going
um adding content to those tabs
customizing your websites look to your
unique self and Publishing and updating
your website as you need all right so
let's build a portfolio so first I'm
going to uh there's a video here on how
to create a new blog post I'm going to
actually blog project I'm going to just
show this to you here itself so when you
click on project and new project you
just go to a new directory what you want
to create here is a quarto Blog and when
you create a quarter blog you give it a
name and you create your project
something like this pops up anyways do
that portfolio example
so while it's opening up
let me show you what the cuato project
would look like it would open up with
some of these files by default like
right out of the bat it would have a few
files so let's see those files again
so these files are just right off the
bat there
um you don't have to create these files
from scratch so the few files that you
see here are cuarto yaml file and
index.quartile markdown and about dot
quarto markdown we're going to Deep dive
and look into every single one of this
but the way you render your project is
you just click on render your website
and just initially the website that it
looks like it's very very clean and I'm
going to come to what that looks like
all right so from here onward I'm going
to switch between our studio and my
presentation so I want everyone to
gather around and just pray to the Live
code gods that everything goes smoothly
but I have everything in the
presentation for you to go back and look
at
all right so when I render it this is
what it looks like just the initial
website I had to do nothing to start
with I'm going to expand that a little
bit but you see here I've got a project
some of my projects I've got a about
page so if you click on that about page
you have an about section with a
photograph description links for
contacting you and uh Twitter and GitHub
links to take you to those pages
obviously right now it just takes it to
github.com because we haven't edited
anything so it's not personalized to me
but right off the bat you see here
you've got a whole beautiful elegant
looking home page Etc so now we're going
to jump into how to edit this stuff
all right before we do that how to edit
my website to look the way I wanted to
I'm going to briefly try to describe the
structure of our blog project and deep
dive into each file so the first
important file that we're going to look
at is a quarto yaml file
um so the quarto yaml file you see here
is uh has a yaml components that
describe what the what my project is so
it's a website type of project the title
of my website that you see here is
portfolio it has a navigation bar and on
the navigation bar it says that on the
right side put this about section which
if somebody clicks whatever content
exists in the about.qmd should open up
then I have the GitHub icon that
references to github.com if somebody
clicks on it so that's what the icon and
href mean similarly there's a Twitter
reference as well the other thing that
you have in the yaml that's important to
note is your format component which says
what should be the theme of my uh
website so by default it picks up a
cosmo theme I'll show you some more
themes you can use but by default it
picks up that theme which has a certain
color schema a font sizes font types Etc
perfect that's the yellow so what yaml
did was give us the structure of the
website the next important file to note
is your index.qmd which is our
index.quartile markdown which always
defines what your home page is going to
look like so what your home page is
means that when somebody clicks on your
website the page that opens up is
defined by your index.qmd so that's
that's what here it looks like so in
this case in our very initial case all
it says is hey
index.qmd title is portfolio I have a
listing component which says this page
should look like a listing of content
and pick up my content from this other
folder called post so there are some
default posts inside that folder which
we'll go over but that's what this yaml
component says so every qmd file
initially in this blog project has this
yaml component and then the markdown
component starts from under the yaml
component so we will see how to edit
both of those and what they do
the next file is the about.qmd so if you
remember our quarto.yaml file said that
if somebody clicks on this open up
whatever is in the about.qmd so what's
in the about.qmd is the is is a template
that says it should look like an about
page which is this it should look like
an about page with the template of July
and we will show other templates as well
and add those links in that template to
reach out to me so
um I showed you three files but just to
recap it very quickly because I think
this is the most important thing to note
when you're trying to uh configure the
website to make it look like the way you
want is you have the index.qmd which is
your home page you have the
cuarto.yaml file which tells you what is
where so where your navigation what's
inside your navigation bar and what the
format of the entire website should be
like you have an about.qmd which is
whatever opens up when you click on
about here
um which doesn't have to be called about
but in this case it's called about so
whatever opens up when you click that
you have CSS files that you can use to
format your file further format your
website further and you have a post
folder which which has all the contents
of whatever you want and it doesn't
which sorry index.qmd calls to say that
hey pick up the post from this
particular folder it can be called
something else it can be called hey pick
go pick up my content from the
visualizations poster uh folder but in
this case it just says okay pick it up
from the post folder so now that that
structure is defined let's go and start
editing the structure the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to play
with the cuarto.yaml file let me I'm
going to close this file right here and
we're going to work with this file that
I have some images in
all right so cuarto.yaml if you remember
I said uh it defines the structure of
the navigation bar so in the navigation
bar let's add the first thing we're
going to do is add tabs whoops
so let's add a home cap so text home and
let's make it
all right it's picking up by default um
and that's a good thing about yaml in
quarto it's like the auto completion is
pretty amazing so you don't have to like
remember a lot of things in the yaml it
just is able to read that by default now
let's make the home page uh point to
index.qmd let's add another
um tab called projects and let's make
that route
it is it loves doing that let me just do
this
uh
projects.qmd and I'm just going to copy
paste this and create one last tab for
my resume uh note that yaml is very
space sensitive to so keep an eye on
like how you're adding the spaces here
all right
but as soon as I save this you will see
the good thing about yamos you're
actually able to see everything add
immediately
perfect there so if I move this here you
saw all these tabs got added when I say
text home it means give this a home text
and refer it to the index.qmd the reason
I like to add a Home tab is because no
matter where you're on the website if
you just want to go to the home page
it's always good for giving that option
that is clear descriptive that if you
click on this you will come to the home
page of the website we already have an
index.qmd so right now when you click on
it this opens up but note that we don't
yet have a projects.qmd or a resume.qmd
so initially right now if you try to
click on this nothing's going to own
because those don't exist and we're
gonna create those in a minute
all right so
I'm gonna close that
going back here
um so just like that we had our cats so
we have like a basic structure of our
website ready now let's add content to
it so the first thing we're going to try
to give this website is a elegant home
page so on the home page I did not want
content right off the bat I wanted my
homepage to look simple like an about
page and so I I used an about template
for my index.qmd so I'm going to copy
paste this to show you what that would
look like
all right so if you go to your index
page I'm going to just delete everything
because I don't want posts on my home
page I want to ease into it and add a
bit of like a description way so if you
edit your index file to say hey use an
about page template called Jola
um add an image to it and I can show you
that while it's rendering okay so you go
into build and when you click on render
that's how you render that website so
use the Jola template take an image give
it this width and make it round and give
my about page the name of deepshamingani
so I use stroller template but that's
not necessarily the template you need to
use so let me show you where you can
find pre-existing about templates from
cuarto so if you just click on the link
in the footnote you can see there's
other templates like this if you wanted
your about page to look slightly
different and there's these other ways
you can do it so note that the image is
in different places your description is
in different places and also these links
that we're going to add later are in
different places so that's how
that's how you can pick it up whatever
template you want so let's add like if I
add a brief description try I'm deepsha
I
like
there if you just render this that will
show up instead of your about this uh
about this blog page so I'm gonna go
back to this
so just like that you can add your
whatever description you want to show up
right here and now let's add these links
so note that based on the template these
links would show up at different places
so I'm going to copy paste this links to
show you
how that would look so when you add the
links is still in the yaml section so if
you just add the links here what it says
is hey add an icon for Mastodon so I'm
gonna
render that to show you what that would
look like
so if you remember I had added and
edited my description so that showed up
right here and what it says is add an
icon for Mastodon which is this m icon
um add text as beside it called Mastodon
and refer to my favorites account if
somebody clicks on it and similarly for
the rest of them as well and so you see
all these different icons Twitter
LinkedIn GitHub contact me they're all
bootstrap icons
um I have used envelope here you don't
have to use envelope you can use a
mailbox icon but where do you go find
all these icons I have linked them right
at the bottom here there is a whole
bunch of icons so let's say I wanted
like a good mailbox icon I can just use
like this if instead of in the icon
instead of envelope if I said mailbox
too this is the icon that will show up
beside it so you can play with the look
of your website there as well
perfect so that is our home page it's
ready now let's update the next uh next
thing which is our resume tab so note
that we don't have a resume.qmd so which
means that if somebody clicks on resume
tab nothing's going to open so I'm going
to go into files and create a resume.qmd
it opens up here now there's two ways
like I talked about earlier that you can
update your resume and one is you if
ever any of us has had to look for a job
we probably have a pdf version of our
resume so the the least resistant thing
to do is to just update upload that
resume in our website as it is if we
don't have the time to create it within
the website itself so let's first look
at how you just embed a PDF within the
website so I embedded my PDF as an
iframe that's if I just add this oops if
I just add this component in my
resume.markdown it would show up like
this so if you see here it would show up
as a PDF in my resume and based on your
website look you can figure out what
height or width that you want so in this
resume if you just copy paste this it
says hey pick up my resume from this
location
um and it'll just show show up like that
or you can update your resume within the
website itself so here if you see that
Wednesday Addams resume is right here
within the website to just give you an
idea of how you can do that I have
linked the GitHub repo for Wednesday
Adams resume that I created you can play
with it edit it see how you feel
creating a resume within the markdown
and once you feel comfortable and ready
you can update your resume.qmd with that
resume and be able to create a resume
like this the I I find this better
because I'm able to like add Charts and
give give my resume more of a unique
look as compared to if I just updated my
resume as a PDF
um all right now we're going to go to I
think the most important part of our uh
portfolio which is the reason we have a
portfolio is to showcase the projects so
I'm gonna uh I'm gonna delete this for
now so that we're not
um trying to embed a PDF but let's say
um Reid did not have a project.2md when
we started but if you remember we told
cuarto.yaml that if somebody clicks on
projects open the projects.qmd file so
I'm going to very quickly create a
projects.qmd file here
all right so I want my projects.qmb file
to look like a page of the screen to
look like a listing of content and the
good thing is quarto already has some
really clean looking templates for
uploading your content so if you just
give it content it would make it look
like this or it would make it look like
a different way based on the template
you use so let's try to create this uh
on the Fly here so what I did here is I
said
around the website I said hey on my
projects.qmd give it a title of pay
title to that page of projects make it a
type of content listing so content
listing and go pick up so if you click
the link here you see now content has
been added so pick up the content from
the post folder I'll show you the post
folder in a second here arrange it in
descending order uh type default I'll
come to that in a second but also add
categories here to each of my content
I'll show you how to add those
um search UI and filter UI is just the
ability for your reader to be able to
sort the content in a portfolio I feel
like you don't have like it's important
that you don't overload it with content
so there is a little bit of content you
don't necessarily need that much of a
sort option
um so it's okay to keep it post but you
can play with it as well because those
are some neat options that are available
um all right so let's now go look add
the pulse folder
so you have two posts posts with code
and welcome so if you see here there's a
post with code and welcome to the blog
let's go inside the post with code and
see what all it contains
so inside my post with code there is an
index.qmd that says hey this is my post
with code it has some executable code
and it shows OnePlus One so if I click
on my post split code that's what you
see here I have a title post with code I
have some categories and I have this
description with some code
um let's close that and let's actually
try to add a brand new post that we
wrote so I'm just gonna use this
template and instead say post with plot
so my post with plot has an index.qmd
and an Associated image with it let's
edit that index.qmd
um this is not a post with code I'm
going to say post with plot and I'm
going to say written author me and just
to Showcase something I'm going to put
the date as a future date for when I
created this
um I'm going to give it some categories
here I'm going to remove the newest
category and I'm going to give it a plot
category and you'll see it up here I'm
going to say okay pick up the image.jpg
to Showcase and where it showcases that
image
is right here this is the image where it
showcase
um this is a post with executable code
I'm going to say no this is a post with
plot and I'm going to just add a plot
here let's do plot empty cars all of our
favorite data sets
so if you see our plot got created
perfect so I'm gonna just once I've done
this
um and actually let me also change my
image
oh crap
save image as and I'm just going to save
that image instead of that previous
image that we have oops sorry about that
large sound and then I just render this
and see how that appears in our post
perfect so this is what that post looked
like that I added but you will also see
that here it got added right here
um so I have my post with plot because
we had told the projects.qmd file that
arranged my posts in a descending order
it it took that latest post because it's
a future date it's showing up as the
first post
um these categories are really cool
because if I just want to see all the
post with code and just click on it and
that shows up all the posts with
analysis and with plot or I can see all
the all the posts
um right here is your image that get
picks up and if you click on it you're
able to see the post so that's how easy
it is to add a new post and if you just
delete the other posts that are here
those just won't show up so my
projects.qmd I said go into the post
folder and pick up all the posts from
there and present it on this website
page so yeah if you don't want your post
folder to look like that or if you don't
want your projects page to look like
this there are some other templates let
me just show you quickly what those
templates look like
so this is a type default so if you
remember here in the yaml section of my
projects.qmd I gave the type default
but if you wanted to say there they are
grid template and this is also a good
template let's say you exceed the number
of projects to more than four or five
I'd recommend using a grid template so
that you're not having the person on
your website keep on scrolling too much
if your website is a little bit heavy
and you want to let's say try to
increase your speed a little and not
have too much images while loading your
website you can also just use a tabular
um a tabular kind of a template in fact
you can have your projects as a
different tab with this template and you
can have a table format for all of your
let's say GitHub repositories like you
want someone to be able to find all of
your GitHub repositories the most
important and interesting ones you can
add that as a tabular tab plane
um so these are like really cool some
base templates that you can start
building with so you don't have to do
anything from scratch okay yeah close
some of these right here
all right
now let's
um go back to this make sure I didn't
miss anything perfect so I'm just
recapping very quickly what we did here
is we created a new folder in the post
tab it had an index.qmd and an image
associated with it
um you can you added and edited the yaml
section you added the description and
whatever plot you wanted and it shows up
in your projects tab by default note one
thing that I'm missing is that this
description is picked up by default I
did not give that in the yaml anywhere
but it gets default picked up from that
first line of your post index.qmd so
that's where this comes from
oops
there we go
so this is
um one thing that I want to show in that
is so this is my post page
um you see here that I not only have
images but instead of that image in yaml
if you just give a gif or GIF it would
show up there as well again recommend
if you do use GIFs I recommend just to
speed up your website like use some gzip
or some type of a software to reduce the
size of your gifs before you upload them
in your website just so that your
website stays speedy all right awesome
so the other thing that I had in my
projects here was external links so
let's say when you sit down to build
your website you've been you've worked
on a lot of projects already and you
don't want to build from scratch the
projects inside your website you just
want to be able to link your external uh
projects in your website so that it's
just again a very quick uh minimal
effort way to just update your website
quickly and if you see this it links to
an external link how do you do that
so in the projects.qmd instead of
telling it that hey this page is a type
of listing I'm going to tell I'm just
going to directly start adding content
to the projects.qmd page so I'm going to
say okay my title is cuarto blog data
visualization animation and
interactivity that's my first blog title
under that blog title I'm going to
divide my page into columns I'm not
going to say initially how many columns
I'm just going to say hey Diva I'm going
to I'm about to divide my page into
columns the First Column with a 55 width
has my description so this is my first
column has my description my second
column just a little bit of Gap it has
nothing
um just so my image and texts are not
too close to each other and my third
column right here with 40 which is the
leftover out of 100 is my image
um and that's how easy it is to just
create this component I wrote the
description myself because there was no
default way is this one is picking up a
description because we're not using a
template here we're giving our
description I tried to make it catchy
enough so somebody would want to
actually click on continue reading and
then open that link and read about it so
that's how you can update that for my
next uh for my next project I wanted the
opposite so I again gave my title for
the next project I divided it into
columns and instead this time I said My
First Column should have image then Gap
then my description so just like that I
was able to customize the look of my
page completely as I wanted it and
there's just so much more uh syntax that
you can play with here within a quarto
HTML
um I'm not going to go over all of that
but I will have links later where you
can learn how many more ways you can
just update your projects page
perfect so I want to take pause here to
tell you that the basic structure of
your portfolio website is done like you
just created your portfolio website you
have your home page which is your about
section you uploaded your resume either
as a PDF or within the markdown you will
uploaded your projects and if you upload
your projects that are already existing
then this would take like 10 20 minutes
um but by this time you have all the
basic components of a portfolio website
ready and clean ready and appear very
cleanly
so let me just show that to you here you
have your home you have your projects
and everything that you need on the home
page you also have ways to contact you
everything as a basic components is
ready so now that we have that structure
down pat even if you didn't do anything
else the website buy Now using the base
quarter template looks clean but let's
customize it further if you want to
um and that we're going to do mostly
after this we're going to stay within
the cuarto.yagle
component okay so if you remember there
were like these default tabs and I'm
gonna show you this here the default
links that were here were only GitHub
and Twitter let's say you want to add
all the links that we had added in the
about
um our about page to that side as well
this is how you can do that so on the
right hand side let me show that to you
here
I'm going to now close all of this and
work in cuarto
so on the right hand side you can add
more uh links here just by giving it a
different icon and a different you can
just keep on adding to this right hand
side and give it the link right now it's
default to github.com but you can
actually give it your own link
perfect so you can do that you can also
add a search icon to your website so the
default when you try to build a website
or a Blog project the default actually
comes with the search option and let me
show you what that by default looks like
so let's say if you want to search your
page
and I want to go to my partly a related
document that I have created so this is
my broadly document but you saw that
when I clicked on search it overlays on
top of the website you can change that
look as well within the quarto Yana so
oops within the quarto yaml so if within
your website component of your yaml if
you give search location navigation bar
type overlay it will overlay let's look
at some more options that you can use
for the default search so there's your
overlay option and there's your text box
option where you don't want to Overlay
really depends upon what look you want
for your website so it can just open up
on the side right here as a text box and
that's your text box box template
there's a lot of other
um
enhancements you can do to your search
like if you go through this page a lot
of other changes that you can do as well
the next thing and I I really like the
success body feature is you can toggle
give the person reading your website to
toggle between dark and light mode Let's
actually try this out here so I'm gonna
just say right now my default theme is
Cosmo which is the same and there's only
one theme instead I'm going to go under
theme and say Hey I want a different
theme for light keep it cross more and
for dark mode I want the dark Lady this
is also a default theme that cuarto has
so if I um if I just add this button
cuarto by default adds a toggle because
it knows you have two themes you cuarto
knows that you want to give the person
reading your website the option to
toggle between the two so it just adds
this button now let's say if you see
there is a lot of differences between
these two my font size change my
navigation bar colors change lots of
things just changed but let's say I
don't want that I want both light and
dark theme to have Cosmo as my theme
like keep all the size and everything
same I just want to change the
background color from white to gray or
to black or whatever to a dark color but
that's all I want to do instead of just
completely changing my theme so you can
do that as well
so here instead of
um dark as a different theme I'm going
to give it this
so here what I'm telling uh my quarter
or yaml is just keep the theme as Cosmo
for both my light and dark moon but in
my dark mode change a few things and
those few things I'm I'm giving it in
this new file I created called theme
dark custom.scss let me just show you
what that file looks like
so this is my theme to our custom.scss
um I think this is a very neat way to be
able to customize a lot of things on
your website like navigation color but
in this case I all I'm changing is my
body background should become dark black
my body color which is my font color
should be white and a few other things
like my link color and my code block
transparency so if I just do that let's
go back to the viewer I saved it and
you'll see here now nothing else is
changing I have Cosmo theme for both of
those but just a few things that I
wanted to change about my theme are now
being picked up from this
so I'm gonna
um show you a link here where you can
change so many this is where you can
pick up your themes from so I used Cosmo
and Darkly initially for the example but
there are so many other themes that you
can pick up with based on what you like
your website to look like
um there is a lot of things here that if
you go down
um all the things that you can change in
your scss files which is also a lot of
things you can change your font family
size
um and a lot of other colors as well and
I'm gonna go over some code block
examples right now
okay
okay so now that we have customized the
Dark theme they looks just so much more
similar and this is what I did for my
website because I like them to be the
same
um everything just a few changes
all right let's come to code block
customizations so code blocks is within
your projects if we open this post with
plot you will see this this is your code
blocks and there is so much
customization that you can do here as
well let's try our first customization
which is code link true
so and this code code customizations are
all still within the theme that we're
doing it so if you just change or if you
just add code link true if this is like
one of my favorite
features oh under the theme so again
because yaml is space sensitive just
make sure that you're adding it at an
HTML level your code link so if you save
it
let's see here
you see here a link just got added
um this feature is really cool because
you if you click on this the
documentation of whatever function
you're using just opens up that quickly
so this is a very cool feature and a
very accessible feature for different
levels of uh people that are reading
your website so just get them up to
speed with what you're building the code
fold as show option what that allows you
to do is
um it's not and I have an example right
here it just folds your code and gives
the audience the option to open and oops
open
appearing here open and close the code
so I'm going to just show that to you
here
now if you do code folding your show it
means that by default it will show but
it'll also give the option to fold the
code so you can fold The Code by default
or not
um the next if you are however giving
the audience to fold your code you want
to also give them the option to either
look at all the code together like
unfold or fold all of the codes
simultaneously so that they don't have
to do that chunk by chunk and that's
where code tools comes in place so when
you add this code to this true option it
adds this on top of your page and it has
the option of showing all the code or
hiding all the code at the same time and
if you it also has this cool feature for
viewing the source which means that hey
if I'm just interested in looking at the
code components of your website or of
your page particularly you can just
click on view source code and it just
shows you that
um I'm not gonna try all of these but I
just wanted to show you where you can
put these examples to play with these uh
scss options
um so code blocks background is just as
the word says code block background I
gave it light blue it's a very not my
favorite color probably I won't do it
from my website but just wanted to show
you this example of you can change your
code block background
um add a border to your code to just
make it look like easy to find I have
done this for my website where I added a
border I made it match the colors I
wanted but you can have a contrast to
your navigation bar or however you want
that however if you don't want to change
or any background or water but you want
to pick up some default themes that are
already there for your code
um there's this really cool like lots of
themes that are available by default
um if let's say you want to take a look
at the example of GitHub theme this is
what it looks like cuarto is smart
enough that it's able to change that
theme for a light and dark mode and
match the code block to whatever theme
of your page is so it's able to this is
your light theme this is your dark theme
um GitHub is one of the options but if
you just click this link
and go to the highlighting section you
have so many other themes Breeze is one
of my favorite things but you can just
like play with these themes see what
looks good with your navigation bar
color Etc that you uh picked
awesome so all right very quickly my
favorite part of uh a website is to add
a fave icon and it is so easy to do in
cuarto if under the website option which
is like right under this option if you
just say hey pick up a fave icon from
this images LinkedIn pic folder it just
adds that right here this is what your
fave icon is so you'll see here my
website has a stop head attached to it
you can have it your pet picture or
whatever you wanted but just gives it a
unique picture versus having it like I
have on my presentation
um which is a globe which opens up for
almost every website that you have if
it's not customized so I think it's a
very cool feature that you can so easily
add in quarto to customize it to have
your look
all right
um I also have website Footers in my
website if you see here at home page and
the reason I have them at website level
is so that
um wherever the person goes they have
this handy and that handy is just says
made with positive contact
deepshaminghani so if at any point in
the while reading the website they're
like oh I want to talk to deepshamingani
or if any at any point on the website
they want to look at the GitHub repo for
the website itself like how I have coded
or built the website that opens up right
away so that is also extremely easy to
add here and I'm gonna just add that to
show you right here
so I just added a page footer section I
said Hey in the center contact deepsha
meghani on the left hand side of my
footer made with cuarto on the right
hand side
um link to my GitHub repo and give it a
background of this color I can change
that background to like whatever color I
want
um
let's change that to red and it just
changes to the red color probably won't
have it it's too bright but you can
change your background to any color
awesome last step we need to publish our
website and I'm going to show an example
of publishing this with quarto pop so
cuanto pop is just one of the ways you
can publish it but it is one of the
easier ways to the easiest way to
publish it and I'll show you that in a
second so in in your terminal just type
the command cuarto publish cuatro Hub
now
if you just press this the first thing
it says is hey you have a quarto pub
account do you want to publish it using
that account I'm going to say yes so if
I Yes means I'm just going to press
enter I'm going to say yes it says oh
publish the name with portfolio I'm
going to say yeah like just publish that
under the name of portfolio and that's
it that's literally it all you had to do
to publish your website so to recap
um first create a free account on
cuarto.pop sign in into your default
browser so that your terminal is able to
know that oh that's the cuarto Pub
account that this person wants to use to
publish their website and then go to the
terminal and give the command up looks
like it just got published there this
link is now publicly available you can
open this link and try it out but that's
how quick and easy it is to publish your
thing go to the terminal and give the
quarto publish and follow the
instructions now updating your website
let's say I've this is not my favorite
color
um for the navigation bar I want to
change that color so I'm going to
re-update the website
um so this could be bigger change than
this I'm just making a minor change but
let's say you added a brand new project
you updated a completely different
resume whatever you want to do you just
make that edit go back to your terminal
again get the same command of Quattro
published
let me go here so you're able to see it
pop and it is able to by default know
that where had you published that
project so it is it it asks you whether
you want to publish these changes to the
same website or you want to create a
brand new website so right now I want to
just publish it to the same website it's
intelligent enough to know that I'm
gonna just
press yes and that's it that change is
now just going to appear online so if I
um just have like some caveats about
quarterback that you need to know while
publishing it using cordobab is the any
website that you publish with it is
publicly visible up there it's published
and the changes made now this is online
any website that you publish with this
is publicly visible it has a limited
size and bandwidth I think all of that
is okay for a portfolio website because
you want it to be public it shouldn't be
too heavy it should have minimal
material so that the people reading your
website are able to actually find things
and are not lost in the plethora of
content that you may want to add so not
add every content but have limited
content on your portfolio website
however if that limitation is not
something that you want there are so
many other ways you can publish your
website uh using quarto pop GitHub pages
is another other way to publish it pause
it connect allows you to have a private
authentication
um so you can publish it publicly or
also have a authentication added to your
website and netify So based on your
needs see what is the way that you want
to publish it
um there's these I've linked here the
page that goes over all the methods of
publishing it and if you click on those
links you will see what are the pros and
cons of each of the publishing system
and the steps on how to do that
so we publish it we have updated it
um I want to place some useful links so
that I can share uh what I use to create
my website these were some of the most
useful links which is
um beautiful reports and presentations
with quarto and building a Blog with
cuarto by Tom and Isabella from posit
teams they were really useful in just
helping me understand how I can lay out
the different pages on my inside my
website if you forget how to publish
with cuarto Pub this is the best 100
seconds you will spend this all like
this this is a YouTube video also by Tom
which goes on goes about how to publish
using cuato pop in 100 seconds and my
portfolio GitHub repo in case you want
to use that as a template to just start
building your website versus trying to
build from scratch feel free to use that
template and then edit from there so
these are some of the useful links and I
I want to just call out that you did it
like if you if this content was useful
in actually building your website like
that's how easy it is to build a website
from scratch with krato so
um I can't believe I actually finished
this content in time Rachel
thank you so much deep Chef that was
amazing
thank you for including all these links
too I just put the
um link to the slides in the chat so
everybody has access to them right away
too
but I do see a lot of questions
let's see I'm going to jump over to a
few on YouTube first and thank you I
know you said you have some extra time
over the top of the hour so we will try
to answer all the questions here and if
you can't stay on or miss your question
it will be included with the recording
too so I just wanted everyone to know
the recording is available immediately
after it ends it will just be at the
same YouTube link
um and so
one of the questions that I see
asked by Marlene and hi Marlene is what
about adding pre-existing our markdown
docs to your projects
um so I actually did have some uh
content in our markdown so initially I
had created my visualization blog using
our markdown but I was easily able to
most of the stuff the code strong
capabilities in our markdown are
Backward Compatible with quarto markdown
so I had to do minor changes to make it
to a quarto file and just update it so
most of the code would just run as it is
with very little intervention in cuato
markdown as well
um regarding actually just keep pasting
a major dot rmd I haven't tried it so I
can't confirm if you can just put an rmd
and it'll work as it is but I would I
changed mine to qmd and update uploaded
it
thank you and I see a lot of people
really loved this question and started
plus wanting it and adding on to it is
there any way to integrate shinyapp into
a quarto website
um yes I actually tried that a few uh
weeks ago for a tidy Tuesday post
um where I learned how to incorporate
shiny and cuarto it is it should be in
my GitHub tidy Tuesday you will able to
find you'll be able to find in either
one of the 2022 or 2023 presentations
but it's so easy to do you can
um cuarto has really good links where
you're able to learn how to incorporate
the shiny in quarto markdown I will add
the caveat though you want your
portfolio website to be really fast and
shiny as as awesome as it is to
incorporate in quarto might slow down
the rent not the rendering but the
actual loading of the website when
somebody comes to that page so see how
incorporating that impacts your website
speed and if it doesn't go for it but it
is it is very easy to incorporate shiny
into your quarter markdown directly one
thing on the note of speed is as you're
building your website add a added
component by component so that not like
every component and then publish your
website they publish it multiple times
to see if you added one component what
happens to the speed of your website if
you added the next one what happens to
so that you're able to find the
bottleneck more easily when you're
creating your website
thank you another question I know you
just touched on a little bit towards the
end about publishing options but
somebody asked Can you publish a quarter
website internally
so I know um and maybe the quantity
might best answer it but I know that
with posit connect you can just publish
your website internally and also have
internal authentication so it's like
even at organization level you can have
authentications so you can definitely do
that not through quarter
thank you and we can share our team can
share a few options uh on publishing in
the chat in just a second here too
um another let me go over to some of the
slido questions
anyway
um and one of the questions there was
is there support for multi-language
websites on Cordo
yes I am actually going to right now my
website is primarily in R but I'm going
to incorporate python into it as well
and you can do that within the same
quartile markdown so you can let's say
call an API using Python and then pull
that API output into our data frame and
then
um plot it using an R using r or ggplot
Nikola Rennie wrote a really amazing
blog very recently
um if you're not following them amazing
uh content comes out of their Twitter
and Mastered on links so
um find Nicola rennie's article on how
to use cuarto to write R and python code
but it is totally doable and and easy to
do
oh um forgot to call it reticulate is
the package that you would use to like
talk between Python and R so you can
either have a silo python document a
silo R document but if you want them to
talk to each other you would use the
reticulate package to make R and python
talk to each other
okay thank you
um and I see some chat uh happening
behind the scenes too and and Curtis has
shared with me that Minnie and Julia's
keynote at the last conference talked
about
um NASA building a website in both R and
python some pages were python notebooks
some were chordo docs so I just want to
say that so Curtis could share it in the
chat as well
um but and for the previous question I
also just posted the the shiny cuarto
and and shiny tidy Tuesday that I had
tried uh in our private chat if anybody
uh wants to take a look at that
perfect I just copied that over
um and then I wanted to also add because
I wasn't sure at first if multi-language
meant R and python or multi-language
also meant for example like English
Spanish French
um and so I have Carlos helping behind
the scenes from the Cordo team as well
um and he did say we have intern
um
we have support for this where users can
choose different languages for different
documents but right now it's not
multiple languages for a single document
and so he shared a link to GitHub
discussions if you wanted to
go over there too I'm just going to put
that in the chat as well that's a that's
a really cool question I did not know
card that could do that that so I'll
keep an eye out for it as well
another question over on slido
was can we create a projects tab that
points to other index projects in other
repos hosted as GitHub pages
oh yeah I'm just going to make sure can
we create a project tab that points to
other index project in other repos
hosted as GitHub Pages
um I'm not sure about that answer but in
my website if you go into the projects
tab it actually links to external stuff
so maybe that way you can link it to
external uh project that was that that
you published using GitHub pages so that
could be one way that you could do it if
I understood the question correctly
thank you very much and I'm copying
questions over for us to save for the
recording as well
um but I see for this question as well
Cordo said uh
Carlos had added yes there's support for
custom listings but it takes more than
200 characters to explain so he linked
to the full docs as well oh sorry I'm
reposting I see Carlos already put it
there thank you
awesome uh let me jump back over
to YouTube here
um and one other question let's see
I'm trying to make sure I don't ask
something similar
here we go here's another one what is
the difference between quarto website
blog and other court order formats
um so but I can definitely talk about
website and blog a blog is a type of
website
um so when you create a website project
or you create a blog project you're
still creating the type of project
called website the reason I chose to
create a blog project because when you
create a website project it it a lot it
gives you a blank slate to start
building from there but when you create
a blog project it had all those files
like yaml and everything by default that
was very quick for me to format to get
it to where I wanted it for my project
but blog is a type of website with blog
you just have components ready to go as
it is and with website you are building
it the way you wanted to from scratch
great thank you another question over on
slido was is it free to deploy a website
from the Cordo platform I have a
portfolio website deployed from GitHub
is it possible to use Cordo and deploy
it from GitHub
to deploy it from I have tried deploying
a website from GitHub Pages separately
um usually if it's a quarto type of
project you should be able to deploy the
same thing in cuanto pep as well
um but not simultaneously as far as I
know but if it's a quarter project you
can deploy the same website that you did
from GitHub oh like I think your
question is the same website just
publish it on cuarto Pub I'm not sure
and to answer the the first question
um is it free to deploy on quarto Pub
yes you can deploy as your own website
over there right now
um and that's where deep shows site
actually lives today so if you see the
the slides and the link that we shared
you'll see it's a quarto pub link
okay let me go jump back over
to slido
oh and this kind of touches on that as
well somebody had asked does this
portfolio live in the cloud do you need
a hosted site to accomplish this
yeah it's it's I have to do nothing to
maintain it which is the biggest reason
that I'm using quarto Pub is in the back
end I I don't have to know what's in the
back end how quattupa is hosting it but
they are doing the maintenance on their
side it's the website is always live so
it doesn't go down
um because it doesn't stop it's not a
server that it stops so
um it's um it's all in the back and done
and maintained you can easily update
your site and you don't have to know
what's happening in the back end for
that
awesome one other question that just
came in on slido is can you embed a
Cordo book into a quarter website or
blog
a quarter book into a website or a Blog
I have tried a quarter doc into a
website and I was easily able to do that
if you just change any I I think you
should be able to do a book uh if you're
using any of like bib tags Etc I don't
know like you can just incorporate that
in there but if there's any book down
specific features
um they are most of them are just
compatible with the Corrado markdown so
you should just be I I did that for my
resume I actually created a docx and I
was easily able to put that exact same
thing to my cuarto some features might
differ that you can see how different
they are and if that's a deal breaker to
change them but it should be doable
great thank you I saw a lot of questions
and conversations and the YouTube chat
around theming as well and I think one
was is it possible to create my own
theme
and I see Carlos has shared a link there
as well and said yes it totally is you
do need to know scss though but there's
some some docs there as well
yeah and and the links that I shared as
one of the Footers
um there is just so much scss that's
available on that page that there is a
lot of custom theming that you can do
from just that page and then you can
like learn scss in different ways but
that page itself has so much content you
can use to customize your theme however
you want
perfect thank you
um so I was curious because I know you
had recently learned Cordo and just gave
this awesome talk what was most helpful
for you in in learning Cordo
um I think the the
talks that you your team did with like
Tom and Isabella I think was just super
helpful
um the flexibility of everything that
you could do
um they did such a great job in showing
how flexible cuarto can be like I just
had so much fun with playing with images
how to make the images lay on top of
each other or come up in a fragmented
manner so there's just so much I could
do with cuarto's uh playing with it
after seeing those presentations just
made it so much easier
I would definitely agree I don't
consider myself a data scientist at all
and I've found it really fun to start
making a website with Cordo too
let me double check over here I see a
lot of uh
people saying thank you so much this was
an amazing presentation great talk
a lot of people saying how incredible it
was so thank you so much deepshat if
there are some
questions that we didn't get to I just
wanted to give people one chance here to
repost that into the YouTube chat I'm
sorry if I missed anything there
I'll give people a second here
but I know all these links that we've
been sharing in the chat today will put
together with the recording as well so
that you'll have them all there as well
as deep shows slides too and all of the
links in her slides
okay I think we're I think we're good on
questions thank you so much deep shy I
really really appreciate it and you
taking the time to answer all these
questions too
thank you so much Rachel
thank you I see somebody was asking real
quick for one of the links that we had
mentioned for a conference talk so I'm
going to share that into the chat here
right now as well
have a great rest of the day everybody
thank